guys I have to tell you had so much fun
watching this movie it was a really nice
break from everything going on right so
Olivia let's start with you what do you
think it is about weddings that brings
up the crazy in people because I do feel
like when you're on a wedding there's
always something that goes wrong yeah
that's another great point I think that
there is there's something about I think
for a lot of people there's this you
know there's the idea the dream of what
they thought a wedding should be like
you know so there there's the execution
of it and you know anything below what
they envision is as a fail probably for
them but I think for other people it's
also there's these these landmarks in
people's lives you know when we grew up
it's like you know you get married you
do this and so I think for other people
it kind of stirs some emotions in them
you know whether it's like you know
they're reassessing their own happiness
in their own marriage or they're
thinking that they should be getting
married I never was the person who ever
thought about getting married as a kid
it was never my thing so I never really
feel that a wedding myself well I feel
like both of your characters in the
movie encounter very interesting
personality so Sam if you had to choose
in real life you're out of wedding who
would you rather deal with an angry ex a
friend who's heavily sedated that you
have to take care of the whole night or
an uninvited guest the secret I feel
like I've done there you know that the
friends that yeah I mean no I mean yeah
the other two I wouldn't I wouldn't even
want to kind of get into a big secret
like that or an angry it's never fun I'm
sure no it just ruins it I think an
angry ex sounds fun tell you the truth
no I do not I just feel like anything
that they would be mad about they're
just projecting onto me and I would have
a field day just having an opportunity
to put them in their place
oh you I'm definitely a great plus-one
anywhere I'm definitely like super loyal
I'm like I'll jump in and say something
I'll be calculated about things it'll
like I'm the one you want
sure yes I deal I deal with stress the
way that Jack sales and stress like
horribly I'm not very good with stress
I'm not very good at juggling lots of
different things yeah I just I just I
just want to hi this is why you're
hiding I'm just getting like behind the
scenes guys on set so Sam was Olivia
always singing in between takes and
trying to get you to show off your
awesome dance moves a fair bit of music
to the didn't you invent that game where
would that was your fried your I came up
with a game but I you would really go
into that more than anyone else the game
the game is yes so Joel fry he came up
with this game it's called well as
designing board but you have to say the
phrase put it on the baking tray and you
have to sing a song and whatever melody
it is but you can only say the words put
it on the baking tray
okay yet you can't repeat the word you
can say like put it on you have to say
like exactly like that so you know like
you like this like put it on the baking
tray nice on the baking tray put it on
the baking tray and then use your guess
what song it is
you know what dominant fools Beyonce
you guys yeah so I want to know what do
you think is the biggest faux pas to do
it a wedding I think we're way if you're
not the bright-red right isn't read like
really distracting for the bride to true
yeah yeah um what is the biggest
football well as a woman that isn't like
the one that everybody looks bad yeah
don't get too drunk don't don't
there's always that bad thing there's
always that one person every single it
just goes one bit too far
usually me but that one person that has
one drink too many and you know just
starts throwing up or everything is one
person distant relative that no one
really knows and knowing yeah yeah
Congrats on the film I had so much fun
and enjoy the rest your weekend